Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper describes a new technique to visualize
the inner workings of a generator neural network.
This is a neural network that is is able to
create images for us.
The key idea here is dissecting this neural
network, and looking for agreements between
a set of neurons and concepts in the output
image, such as trees, sky, clouds, and more.
This means analyzing that these neurons are
responsible for buildings to appear in the
image, and those will generate clouds.
Interestingly, such agreements can be found,
which means way more than just creating a
visualizations like this, because it enables
us to edit images without any artistic skills.
And now, hold on to your papers.
The editing part works by forcefully activating
and deactivating these units and correspond
to adding or removing these objects from an
image.
And look!
This means that we can take an already existing
image, and ask this technique to remove trees
from it, or perhaps add more, the same with
domes, doors, and more.
Wow!
This is pretty cool, but you haven’t seen
the best part yet!
Note that so far, the amount of control we
have over the image is quite limited.
And fortunately, we can take this further,
and select a region of the image where we
wish to add something new.
This is suddenly so much more granular and
useful!
The algorithm seems to understand that trees
need to be rooted somewhere and not just appear
from thin air.
Most of the time anyway.
Interestingly, it also understands that bricks
don’t really belong here, but if I add it
to the side of the building, it continues
it in a way that is consistent with its appearance.
Most of the time anyway.
And of course, it is not perfect, here you
can see me struggling with this spaghetti
monster floating in the air that used to be
a tree, and it just refuses to be overwritten.
And this is a very important lesson - most
research works are but a step in a thousand-mile
journey, and each of them tries to improve
upon the previous paper.
This means that a few more papers down the
line, this will probably take place in HD,
perhaps in real-time, and with much higher
quality.
This work also builds on previous knowledge
on generative adversarial networks, and whatever
the follow-up papers will contain, they will
build on knowledge that was found in this
work.
Welcome to the wonderful world of research!
And now, we can all rejoice because the authors
kindly made the source code available free
for everyone, and not only that, but there
is also a web app so you can also try it yourself!
This is an excellent way of maximizing the
impact of your research work.
Let the experts improve upon it by releasing
the source code, and let people play with
it, even laymen!
You will also find many failure cases, but
also cases where it works well, and I think
there is value in reporting both so we learn
a little more about this amazing algorithm.
So, let’s do a little research together!
Make sure to post your results in the comments
section, I have a feeling that lots of high-quality
entertainment materials will surface very
soon.
I bet the authors will also be grateful for
the feedback as well, so, let’s the experiments
begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!